[Music]
gotcha so you're the funny little man
who's been following me funny little man
how dare you I will have you know that I
am a perfectly respectable size for
Ana NOA what now in fact in Lumpa land I
am regarded as something of a Whopper
they call me lofty
sorry ladies and gentlemen greetings to
you all my name is Willie won you see
I'm something of a magician prepare to
be amazed
tap inventor may I present Willy W's
wild and wonderful wishy-washy Wakka
Walker please don't make me say that
again and chocolate
Baker the best chocolate in the
world
ooh he's good good too good and anyone
can afford them even the the poor he
doesn't like it when people say p send
Wonka a message do not sell chocolate in
this
town you're going to get more than a bon
on the head I love a B on the head what
is with me
today you should stand up to those
Buddhist give them the old one
two I got an idea where do we start
making chocolate of course
[Music]
run away every good thing in this world
started with a
dream so you hold on to
yours I guess it's time to change the
world
[Music]
good night sir I am going
flat
huh what is it nothing well it's
obviously something because you said huh
forget it very well
[Music]
huh you did it again tell me what it is
or I shall poke you quite viciously with
a cocktail
[Music]
stick